lufthansa flight 456 takes off from
frankfurt airport destination los
angeles
the transatlantic route used to be a
good money earner but as more and more
airlines cover the same leg prices are
sinking
prices have also dropped within europe
no frills carriers like ryanair have
steadily chipped away at lufthansa's
customer base and that's why lufthansa
uses its own no-frills airline german
wings for many domestic routes
partner airline euro wings could also
soon be offering cheap flights to
destinations within europe
it's unusual to want different brands in
the low-cost segment at first it seems
hard to understand but on the other hand
you have to consider the price
structures
i think that the work environment at
eurowings is more economical than at
german wings
so that could be the decisive factor for
lufthansa
former lufthansa ceo christophe france
passed on the priority of cost cutting
to his successor casting spore here on
the right
spore has been at lufthansa for over 20
years he earned his commercial pilot's
licence with the airline
until recently he was the head of the
passenger business
spore has a reputation for being
communicative and easy going which could
help him improve the gloomy mood amongst
staff only satisfied employees can
provide good customer service and that's
key to attracting frequent flyers
asian and african markets are also
problem areas
gulf based airlines like emirates qatar
airways and etihad airways now dominate
the market with help of rich royal
families they have been buying many new
aircraft and brought down prices
i think lufthansa's asia strategy will
require it to forge strong ties with one
of these airlines either emirates or
turkish airlines
the new lufthansa boss will have to
tackle many challenges to keep the
airline flying high